c'est avec la même joie et la même
retenue que France Mitterrand et Jacques
Chirac ont saluaient ce soir la
libération des trois otages français du
Liban dans une intervention télévisée en
direct de l'Elysée le chef de l'État a
remercié tous ceux qui ont permis
aujourd'hui leur retour
mesdames et messieurs
la libération de Messieurs Marcel carton
Marcel fontaine et Jean-Paul Kaufman me
remplit de joie
au nom du pays tout entier
j'exprime à nos trois compatriotes ainsi
qu'à leur famille de ne pas notre
soulagement de les voir revenir parmi
nous
à leur famille il a compassion que nous
inspire une si longue épreuve
je suis heureux que les efforts
entrepris depuis le début de ce drame
est enfin abouti et je remercie tous
ceux qui ont œuvré pour ce retour
nous aurons aussi une pensée pour celui
qui n'est pas revenu
Michel sera
et pour les siens
ainsi que pour les otages étrangers
encore retenus au libre